I have some very interesting voicemails
to play for you today our voicemail
number is two one nine two david p the
voicemail line sponsored by our friends
over at linguist which is an artificial
intelligence based language learning
service which i've been using to improve
my French and I'm impressed with myself
I know some people in the audience won't
be shocked to hear about that but I'm
patting myself on the back for how well
I'm doing with my French learning thanks
to linguist which lets you really
improve in a short amount of time you
can try it for free no credit card
needed Ling viscom / Pakman that's Ling
list with a V comm / Pakman ok I have
two voicemails for you today they both
relate to my interview with Natalie wind
from contra points that we aired before
you over the last couple of days I
really wasn't sure whether the to play
these voicemails for you and there are
more than just these two because they're
disgusting transphobic voicemails but I
thought it important to play them for
you because this is the right which
claims to be against identity politics
playing identity politics these are
examples of people on the right
disgustingly saying I don't care what
Natalie Wynn had to say because of her
identity as a trans woman
first is the horribly racist Kansas
troll who comes back out of the woodwork
to be transphobic on the show take a
listen
yo yo dude I can't believe it you
finally did it man you have three
trainees on the show at one time it's
not just you and Patrick anymore you
have this freak thing that you invited
for an interview
hey and this thing that calls itself
Natalie is totally mentally ill I don't
know why you call you she or he or
Natalie because it's obviously it's dude
like it's dude yeah as you can sell no
criticisms at all of the very good
information that Natalie laid out about
fascism and authoritarianism also Jamie
from Philly a rabid rabid Trump
supporter calling in about the same
thing
David this is Jamie from Fairy Amrit
this is regarding an ally win counter
post you you can
you gotta be kidding me that this
disapproves you're so disingenuous why
do you describe this person masquerading
as a woman as a man because that's the
truth David this is a person that is a
man masquerading as a woman yeah
disgusting and as you can tell not able
to refute the arguments so you go ad
hominem and by the way ad hominem about
something that I mean listen what when
guests appear on the program to talk
about economics we don't talk about
their gender when guests appear on the
program to talk about fascism we don't
talk about their gender and and this
unrealistic and disgusting identity
politics that a lot of people on the
right responded with to my interview
with Natalie really depressing but I
think it is important not to hide from
the audience the fact that this was a
significant portion of the reaction from
the write about what I thought was a
really informative interview we've got a
great bonus show for you today get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at WWJ pakman.com or a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show